hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to do a
couple chess puzzles and take you
through my train of thought so with this
puzzle here it's black to move and the
only information that I really have is
about this puzzle is that it allows you
about a hundred seconds on chess comm to
try and figure it out that has to do
with a rating that you could acquire
when you try and work these puzzles out
so that's some information to me
concerning this problem but beyond that
what is the best continuation my first
thought no if you'd like to try to
figure this out on your own I would
suggest you just go ahead and pause the
video I'm just going to go in and share
my thoughts right away so my very first
thought is centered around this five
square because it's a forcing move so
I'm really looking at forcing moves
Queen check here and additionally this
Bishop is unprotected so I'm thinking
after Queen check a move that is needed
is something like the bishop blocking
and then what could be done I'm not sure
Queen check Bishop to f4 to block and
then well actually you could just grab
this Knight
so I believe that this is just going to
be it that one's not too bad I don't
know I don't think I think that this is
correct if Queen check and the Queen
blocks well right now she is currently
restricted because she has to watch over
this Knight this right here I view as
unprotected as well as the Bishop Bishop
zero tacker zero defenders right now one
attacker one defender I consider these
two unprotected so it seems pretty clear
to me at least and this is it is showing
that this was the best move there is a
queen block there is a bishop block but
I think however you slice it there ends
up being piece 1 by black so the move
here is not to take the Queen because
the knight wood recapture so you just
take the knight at that point and that's
pretty much it so they I don't think
they're going to go any further it's
just considered at that point that the
problem is solved so that one wasn't too
bad let me try
just one more problem in maybe it'll be
a little bit more difficult so okay whoa
okay we got four Queens on the board and
in this position it's white to move and
[Music]
they're allotting 212 seconds to figure
this out so that's again just gives me
some insight as to the difficulty level
so here's my first thought my first
thought is not what white can do but
rather what black can do even though
we're looking I'm looking right now for
the best move for white I'm seeing that
if given time black could just end up
giving checkmate and so I believe that
the first move in other words is going
to have to be of the first move by white
is going to have to be a very forcing
move so right away I'm just looking at
all checking moves Queen check here but
really it's this square that I'm
thinking about more so than the g8
square squares that two or more pieces
can go to I'll often look at those
squares first so the Queen could go here
to give check there's also a knight here
that could give check and in total
there's only three checking moves a
knight check and a queen check too both
of these squares so let's see if I think
after a knight check here I'm not so
sure what the follow-up would be I think
it's actually Queen to the corner Queen
h8
and there's only one reply Bishop takes
and then and then I think Knight check I
think Queen check is to kick this bishop
off of the seventh rank so that this
Queen could come in and eventually
converge on this square right here g7 so
let me let me think a little bit more on
this I don't know I don't know that
there's really going to be a better move
after Knight check pawn captures I'm
just not seeing it the Queen could give
a check but you could take with the king
at that point and then if there's a
queen check here you just come back up
and that's not so sure what the follow
up would be so I believe the first move
in some sense you could kind of cheat
with these puzzles to try and solve them
but I'm trying to see what the solution
is instead of just going move by move
I'm pretty sure that this is the correct
first move but I want to be able to see
see it through as if this was an actual
game you wouldn't be able to just go
kind of move by move and know that it's
going to work out you don't have those
sort of hints so let's see
Queen check bishop takes is the only
move Knight g5 a check by g5 check
that's the only move excuse me after the
Knight g5 check what would what would be
the options there's a king move but I
believe Queen here would just be made so
the only other thing is to just take the
night but after Queen d7 if the King
goes to g8 then there's another check
followed by maid in the corner and the
other option is to actually come up to
this h6 square again being able to
visualize that after Queen check King
takes all right excuse me after Queen
check Bishop takes after Knight check
this pond captures so then this square
is h6 square is now available for the
king so we would have queenie seven king
h6 and then the queen or the pond could
capture i think i'm seeing the mate the
queen ends up on g4 giving me let me see
queen check this is the last trial run
here queen check Bishop takes Queen
Knight g5 check pawn takes Knight Queen
to e7 check King h6 pawn takes g5 with
check King to h5 and is there even a
faster mate I was thinking queen h7
because it's very forcing queen h7 King
takes g5 Queen been to h4 King to f5 and
then Queen to g4 and I believe that that
would be me unless there's something
faster at least I'm seeing some mate I'm
pretty sure
but yeah hopefully this is this is the
first move yes okay it is okay so that
is the first move and now Knight g5 that
is also correct pawn takes Queen to e7
check and okay so instead the computer
is going in this direction which I
believe is just going to now run into a
mate until 2:00 a CH 6 we have pawn
takes the computers just kind of playing
out all the different possibilities
art-lete should say it's just choosing
one of the possibilities so now to mate
into the Queen key go to any one of
these two squares followed by mate in
the corner saying that that's correct I
don't know I'm assuming it would also
say that that is all right now that
wouldn't but that isn't the best move I
was thinking da Tori 8 but if you go to
d8 the King could have gone to f7 so
this is that is the move to go to be 8
at that point and then grab the bishop
so they're saying that the problem is
solved right there so just a little bit
of insight with just these couple
problems and hopefully you can use that
train of thought or implement some of
those ideas when it comes to unprotected
pieces like we saw in the first puzzle
and then in this second puzzle right
here when it comes to trying to find the
best move for white maybe it's better to
first see what it is your opponent can
do in this case what it is that black
can be doing if given the opportunity to
have a shot at your King is there
forcing move in other words what is the
threat that your opponent can be having
these are some things to be thinking
about at least when you're trying to
solve these puzzles so that's all for
this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye